ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show i was uh coming down my
elevator this morning and i opened it
and there was like an autistic uh kid or
like a young
maybe in his teens late teens and he was
like he was in the elevator and he was
like press far
press far
and the guy and i was like terrified
because the elevator opened and he was
just sweating and screaming
press far
like as loud as i'd ever heard and there
was like a saudi next to him like a
skinny saudi like one of the 19 hijacked
they just all look alike it's he didn't
do it but they just as skinny saudi
think any of them muhammad or whatever
and he's and not that they're all but
you know what i mean it's that aesthetic
in the elevator next to this kid and
then i'm like all right i'll wait for
another one and then the saudi walks out
he goes i'll wait for another one too
and i'm like what the [ __ ] happened he
goes i don't know who this guy is
i just walked in the elevator and he
started screaming press four
press four he started hitting the call
button and screaming at security
so like the the mental it's crazy
what's going on out there and then i was
eating lunch in a grocery store and a
guy just came up to me i swear to god
out of nowhere and he was going up to
everyone in the store and he's going you
know a guy i met told me he goes you
know what i do i provide drugs to the
rolling stones and i said no way and
then he got keith richards on the phone
and i played him satisfaction and he
liked it so and then he goes so what
he's a drug dealer you never know
and i go okay
and he's going up to everyone in the
store
and telling them that exact story over
and over word for word no variation
just going up to like the next person
who's like getting a tomato and going
i met a guy and you know what he said he
did he get he sold drugs he provides
drugs to the rolling stones i said no
way get keith richards on the phone and
you know what he did and then i played
him satisfaction and he liked it so he's
a drug dealer but you never know
and then there'd be like a woman ladling
soup into a thing and he goes a guy i
met came up to me and he said i provide
drugs through
and everybody is just kind of like
nodding like yes
and and it just
the level of mental illness in the
country now is so obvious
like it's glaring it's in your face if
you're not recognizing it you're not
paying attention
it's so
out in front
i mean
so many of the people that you
come across
on a day-to-day basis have lost it
they're no longer playing the game
you're playing in reality they're
somewhere else
you know nervous breakdowns psychic
breaks
you know
trauma-induced schizophrenia i don't
know but people are wandering around the
world right now
so much so that it's not shocking
anymore
like you're like yep that guy's you know
you used to be like oh that guy's not
now you're just like up that's the guy
that
talks about the rolling stones at lunch
every day there's nothing anyone can do
and you know
and the thing is he's not like frothing
at the mouth
put him in the home crazy
he's just like
kind of like let's we can tolerate it
fine
he tells a nice little story over and
over again
crazy the elevator guy the kid in the
elevator was a little a little too nuts
and to where even the saudi guy walked
out he goes i'll take the next one
because yeah he just came in started
screaming he was sweating at this watery
hair and he scratched that's far that's
far far
and i was just like i pay a lot of money
to live in this building
um
but this is what happens right i mean
this is but you know a friend of mine uh
has a job as like a companion and and
it's kind of a sober companion but what
he also does is very wealthy families
will pay him
to spend time with their children and
their children could have um
debilitating addiction that could have
severe autism and you know
his job is to and you know i feel for
all of those people in all of those
situations you know what i mean like uh
but his job is to like walk them around
central park or like
hang out like try to make things
better for them because it is very
difficult
um but it was very jarring when the
elevator door is open his god pass far
and i don't know
i also get mad because i think what
happened was he was trying to go to four
and somehow we ended up on my floor and
i also you know i've had that happen to
me but you could tell something wasn't
right with him like he was like spitting
as he talked and sweating some press
four
and i was just like oh my god his
clothes were weird you know it's just a
strange he looked like the guy get up
recess
get up the bully on on the show recess
it was a cartoon that i used to watch
uh
yeah randall so go right right okay so
yeah he looked exactly like randall from
recess the guy in the elevator going
press far press far i told you press far
i just kept saying press four press four
press four
so it was a little traumatic it was an
interesting day just noticing how many
people are just not with it
they're off
and there's nothing to be done and as
long as they're not trying to kill you
you just have to let it go
which is what you should you know you go
hey
but it is something you can notice you
know
um
we were talking the other day about
um
hollywood
on this show
and we had mentioned the batgirl movie
that had gotten
shelved
meaning they're not releasing it
and there's a lot of people that
um were confused about that um and they
were thinking was that a marketing ploy
were they you know trying to say like
hey
uh they they thought maybe there'd be an
outpouring of like no we really want to
see batgirl
uh for whatever reason they're not
releasing it
um
and you know there's this idea that
everyone in hollywood's like is a
lunatic uh but they're that's only true
of certain people
and there are certain people that are
actually good and they're actually
people that are
trying to do the right thing and they
are good a good example
they're like an example for people and
one of them
and again this is a non-binary person so
i'm going to try to do this
the right way and use all the right
things because i believe in you
but it's hard
and difficult to always remember so
don't
come for me if i say the wrong thing
but this is about an actor who is
actually a very
uh
this is someone you want to if you're a
child you want to kind of emulate this
guy
um who's not a guy who's see again
already already it's hard literally
already
it's this person this entity
um ezra miller
ezra miller is a non-binary
actor
who is a great role model for children
and there you see them you see them
there nothing awkward about saying that
you see them there you see them there
good seems good english everyone you see
them there
with
uh a skull necklace and a fur coat
now
ezra miller
has been having
problems yes with the studio who is
releasing the movie the flash the studio
is called warner brothers
and there is a movie coming out called
the flash
it is a superhero movie of course it is
because um
we will refuse to make any movies
anymore unless they are about
superheroes or slaves those are the two
genres of film that we are interested in
making
uh
you're either being beaten and whipped
in a field or you're flying through the
air trying to save someone those are the
only two representations of any person
you will see
in cinema at the current moment
ezra miller was in this called the flesh
now what's going on with ezra miller
there's uh issues
there's problems right a long timeline
of uh legal troubles he's had a stay day
oh they
i'm
sorry because he choked
someone and kidnapped someone does not
mean
that you we can get all loosey-goosey
here with the terms
uh
ezra miller
early in the pandemic video leaked of
miller
choking a woman outside
the
i don't even want to pronounce it but in
reykjavik iceland it's a bar
in the clip which seems to pick up
mid-confrontation
a smiling woman approaches miller and
appears to start a play fight
well
is this going to be one of those things
we have to side with them
miller takes her motion seriously and
says okay you you want to fight that's
what you want to do before grabbing the
woman by the neck pushing her against
the dumpster throwing her to the ground
at which point the video cuts out seems
excessive hey
ezra
at the time variety confirmed miller's
identity with the bar which said miller
frequent did the location when they were
in town so he choked a woman yes not
great not good not great pr for the
flash
in on january 27 2022
miller began their fateful year by
posting a video to social media
threatening a north carolina faction of
the ku klux klan this is a message for
the
blueville
buellerville beulaville chapter of the
north carolina kkk the actor says neclip
um look if you all want to die
i suggest killing yourselves with your
own guns okay otherwise keep doing
exactly what you're doing right now and
you know what i'm talking about then you
know we'll do it for you if that's what
you really want it's unclear what
prompted miller's threat to the hate
group
he has no known ties to the north
carolina city
see that's what makes me laugh is it's
not just a kkk in general it's a
specific
north carolina almost like he has a
problem
with a person in that specific faction
of the north carolina
uh chapter of the klu klux klan in
beulahville in beulaville like listen
guys uh we are going to figure out
what's going on
with the beulahville kkk
um
march 28 2022
hawaii arrest number one miller spent
their spring in hawaii by all accounts
they were a menace
to everyone around them
on march 28th the actor was visiting a
local karaoke bar when they grew
agitated and began quote yelling
obscenities and at one point grabbed the
microphone from a 23 year old woman
singing karaoke
later miller london a 32 year old man
and failed to calm down after being
asked several times by the bar owner
miller's interactions with the two bar
patrons earned them
and by the way i can't get anything made
because i sat next to alex jones on a
podcast
just to give you an idea
this person
is being this is all okay
who does he have photos of
they who do they have who do they when
did ezra miller come out as non-binary i
think a few years back okay right well
it's clearly helped their behavior
so
miller then post 500
bell
they let him out
yeah yeah um miller argues that they in
fact were the victim of assault claiming
his self-identifying nazi in the bar
attacked him there's always nazis
everywhere popping up
a nazi in the bar attacked them
and explaining that they recorded
themselves being assaulted in order to
make nft crypto art
so ezra miller said i was attacked by a
nazi
and i recorded it to make crypto art
yeah basically he's accusing you sing
the knots he was doing they they are
saying
[Music]
when does he okay shortly after the
karaoke bar incident miller was arrested
again in hawaii for allegedly throwing a
chair that struck a woman in the head
at around one in the morning can i do
this if i become non-binary
can i throw chairs at women
and go crazy at bars in hawaii like
can i do all of that is that because by
the way i don't feel
really to be honest i didn't feel like a
man or a woman today i had uh
tomatoes and onions and and i rolled it
up and i didn't eat any bread and i
rolled it up with locks and cream cheese
and i ate it in the grocery store and i
just sat there while the crazy guy
talked about the rolling stones i didn't
feel my [ __ ] i if i had a vagina that
would have also been okay like i i felt
kind of like either one so what i'm
saying is if i fully embrace my kind of
gender neutral fluid identity can i
choke women outside of bars and throw
chairs at their head
it's a ki it's a fair question
um
this is one of those things with ezra
miller where everybody goes you got to
look into it you got to look into it you
got to look into it i've never looked
into it i just ignored ignored ignore it
because like
you know what i mean
so
then miller was accused of acting
inappropriately toward two different
children first the parents of iron eyes
an 18 year old environmental i mean
folks
the parents of toccata iron eyes
and
an 18 year old environmental activist
sought a protective order against the
actor saying who they began
and inapprop maybe you don't get your
pronouns um
honored if you throw chairs at women's
heads
could that be a good rule where we go
hey so for if you are going to be
violent we're not going to actually
honor the pronouns
so this is what they said
they said
miller began an inappropriate
relationship with iron eyes when they
were 12 years old ezra uses violence
intimidation threats of violence fear
paranoid delusions and drugs to hold
sway over young adolescent takata
iron eyes parent said however posts from
an unverified instagram account believed
to be owned by iron eyes denied all
claims of abuse
so the parents claim one thing but iron
eyes
says nope
we're doing fine
soon after a 12 year old and their
mother were granted an order of
protection from miller after describing
an uncomfortable interaction with the
actor during a party in greenfield
massachusetts the mother and then her
11-year-old attended a party held by
their downstairs neighbor which miller
also attended at the event miller began
screaming in the mother's face after
accusing her of cultural appropriation
and allegedly showed her a gun
saying quote talking like that could get
you into a really serious situation
after that miller reportedly now by the
way
you know i know gavin just got clipped
and everyone's gonna be you know and i
don't know what he did and gavin's
always been good to me but i
you know
here's the deal everyone's gonna be
talking about right-wing terrorism every
news article that you're gonna read for
the next 12 months will be about
right-wing terrorism which again
does exist
for sure there are paramilitary groups
that do crazy things capital right
whatever but
this type of behavior where he's like
showing a gun
to someone say talking about cultural
appropriation could we then move this
into the category of a guy who is maybe
influenced by the left a bit to doing
some things that are inappropriate
um because he's using all like the
terminology and he's got the gun and
he's still in the movie yet
i imagine if this was kind of on the
other side where he was talking about
the great replacement theory or any you
know and brandishing guns he might not
work that's all curious
i don't know
um so he points a gun at a mother's face
at a party
uh because she said something she i
don't know what she said after that
miller reportedly acted inappropriately
toward the child by hugging them and
touching their hips they automatically
were just weirdly drawn to me and kept
talking about how they love my outfit
they love my style
it was really uncomfortable i was
nervous i was scared to be around them
after he'd yelled at my mother and she
was crying why the mother then didn't
leave the party is odd to me
in august 2022 those closest now by the
way this person still has a job
they still after all the [ __ ] right the
me too the canceled culture
every this guy that's not a guy that's a
woman too that's non-binary that's lives
in the middle and it's just hard because
the name ezra
has always been a male name this is
difficult it makes me
but
they
the choker
the choker and the brandisher of guns at
the mom
still has a job in hollywood odd
interesting
um
in august those closest to miller spoke
to insider for a report that paints the
actor is increasingly unstable really
and apparently running sort of a call
the report alleges that while miller was
in iceland in 2020 they walked around
town barefoot sporting long unclip
toenails what may have been an infected
gash on their foot
miller rented an airbnb in the reykjavik
suburb of coppa vulgar and they ran a
commune with beds laid out on the floor
for artists expats and young women
they group led men they led group
meditations and claimed to possess
supernatural powers and also paid for
food lodging and marijuana but would
become violent if they perceived any
dissent within the group these days
miller runs another commune in vermont
which he which has been described as
having rampant drug use and unsecured
guns a woman and a by the way
what is going on at warner brothers
how persuasive is this guy because you
know cold leaders can be charismatic how
charismatic
is this guy
that warner brothers is going yeah let's
just we'll figure it out and by this guy
i don't mean gendered guy i mean like i
mean like i call my friend michelle what
up guy
um
so miller's running a commune in vermont
yeah
um rolling stone ran a whole article
about that too like like the mainstream
media has picked it up guns bullets and
weed he was housing three young children
at this farm there were guns laying
everywhere the one-year-old had a bullet
in their mouth
they've been reporting on this for a
minute yeah so i i now go to the article
about warner brothers where everything's
kind of okay
because ezra miller came in and like
apologize like i i'm like but my mind is
blown
by the fact
that this person
i mean how good of an actor are they
maybe they're great
it's kind of is where he met with them
miller who uses they them pronouns in
medsker met with new warner brothers
film chairs michael deluca and pamela
abby to discuss
not only how to stay on course for the
flash's june 23 2023 release date but to
reaffirm their commitment to the movies
wells apologize for bringing negative
attention to the production in the
company
over the past few years miller has been
at the center of arrest a controversy
culminating with the actor posting me a
culprit on august 15 saying they were
seeking help from mental health issues
said the actor at the time i want to
apologize to everyone that i have
alarmed and upset with my past behavior
according to sources miller vowed to
seek help after learning that deluca and
abdi were considering all options for
flash including scrapping the 200
million dollar movie
if things devolved further with miller
200 million
while the actress said to not have
minded the stream of bad headlines they
were spooked by the notion of the film
getting cancelled and jolted to take
action
they care about the flash it's one of
their favorite characters to play i mean
it's we're just living in a [ __ ]
disgusting
you know i mean it's like a joke it's
like a complete we're just living in a
complete joke you know
i mean it's you know i drive around this
town and you know today the tour you
know the tour buses and some of them are
like legit tour buses some of them are
just these little vans that are sawed
off and they have no you know no roof
and
one of the guys recognize me give me the
peace sign or whatever and you know i'm
like
you know like they're they're driving
around here and i'm like
you know get off these things like get
off these [ __ ] whatever you're
looking for here
whatever
stardom you're looking for is in
reykjavik iceland running a cult
like the it's it's such a joke the town
has become such a complete joke to
people
it's a punchline of a joke
that i i'm amazed that that industry
still exists the tourism industry where
people are like show me the star i mean
it's just it's hilarious that's neither
here nor there
um
i mean it's it's it's you know listen
yeah felony burglary on august 7th yeah
he broke into someone's house and stole
their liquor
and he got caught for that
in vermont
all right well listen
he they thing annoys me so much we're
not going to talk about it anymore
um
is this part of coming out as non-binary
in hollywood the ability to do all of
these things is this part of it
if it's part of it i think i would
actually like to do it and i would like
to get on board as soon as possible with
it i'm i'm unaware of what makes
violence against women and children uh
okay and what makes uh running a cult
okay but apparently
you know i don't know it's strange it's
strange i have no interest in the flash
either way i don't care i don't care
about any of these i'm sick of these
superhero movies i'm sick of the
children uh that watch them and by
children i mean 35 year old losers that
are into [ __ ] superhero movies you're
disgusting
you're a disgusting person
and i only watch movies from the 90s ben
knows this if i have a movie night at my
house i only watch films from the 90s in
the early 2000s uh for the most part i
don't want to be involved in any of this
freak show that's going on right now
where people with peter pan and i know
that the studios are not making money on
other movies so they have to make these
to go global fine and some of them are
enjoyable you know what whatever um
you know the big one with the hulk and
thor what was that one the avengers and
all that listen i i'm not saying that
they're you know listen they're fun
every now and then the fact that it is
the only genre of entertainment in
america is disgusting
the fact that it is the sole genre of
which you can partake in going to see a
film is disgusting
because this is a country that has a lot
of old people there's more old people
than young there's going to be so many
old people because of the birth deficit
or whatever that there's so many old
people
and all of the movies are a superhero
movies so
that's crazy to me
and uh
that just upsets me
but this story is just funny to me
because it is funny how many buttons
this person can push
how much criminality they can be
involved with uh and
warner brothers just goes yeah whatever
it's cool it says full steam ahead in
the article full steam ahead good full
steam ahead well
you know
maybe ron desantis will put the military
in there i mean it's what'll you know i
don't know i'm just saying like
you know it's
it's like uh you know it's crazy
if ron desantis i will support him right
now if he promises to use the military
to get me work in this town like if ron
desantis will use the military to
literally go into these companies
with guns drawn and make me a star of
some of these
superhero films i will support ron
desantis and if he's if he's man enough
to make that promise where he will use
the military the power the full power of
the united states military to put boots
on the ground
in beverly hills
and hollywood
and get me jobs
then i will support him and i know that
i'm sure he's looking for an endorsement
from this show
that is the uh that is what is needed
that is the requirement for a desantis
endorsement is him using the military
to replace uh ezra miller with me
in the flash in the new
flash film
from cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts and it really hurts
that's why i started using upside upside
is an incredible app for anyone who buys
gas groceries or dines out with every
purchase i'm earning cashback thanks to
upside i mean you can use it at grocery
stores or i use it at gas stations get
started download the free upside app use
my promo code timd and get five dollars
or more cash back on your first purchase
of 10 or more next claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside check
in at the business pay as usual with
credit or debit card and get paid in
comparison to credit card rewards or
loyalty programs you could earn three
times more with cash back with upside
upside issues earning
upside users are earning more than a
million dollars every week that's
probably why they have a 4.8 star
writing on the app store download the
free upside app and use promo code tim d
to get five dollars or more cash back on
your first purchase of ten dollars or
more that's five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more using promo code tim d
you just i just use the app when i get
to the store i just check in so i don't
have to upload my receipt and it's all
oh it's so simple yeah it's really easy
the cash appears in your upside account
you can cash out at any time through
bank transfer paypal e-gift card to
amazon starbucks and dozens of other
places there's no limit to how much you
can earn this is super easy to use most
businesses don't require you to upload
receipts you can just click check in on
the app and you can transfer the cash
you've earned right to your checking
account it's real cash back
no points or loyalty rewards here users
get real cash and can cash out at any
time upside also works with with other
loyalty cash backing credit and debit
card rewards program
it's loved by businesses and users alike
users are earning three times more cash
back with upside than any other product
including loyalty programs and credit
card rewards
really it's very interesting because
you're gonna do this stuff anyway you're
gonna go to the grocery store the gas
station so why not check in and make
some money back
when i tried this i didn't believe it
worked but it works
it works yeah and even if you share it
with your friends it helps increase your
earnings real cash it's you know
everybody needs a little bit of cash
profiling surveillance data harvesting
there are lots of things not to like
about the tech giants
but what can you actually do about it
when you rely on so many of their
products
we don't all have 44 billion dollars to
go buying up twitter and that guy didn't
even do it but the good news is you
don't need to be a billionaire to take a
stand for less than seven dollars a
month you could join me and fight back
against big tech by using expressvpn
how do you think big tech companies like
twitter make all their money anyway well
by tracking your searches video history
and everything you click on and then
selling your personal data
expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your ip address a unique
identifier that has every device that
allows big tech to match your activity
back you
that's why i use expressvpn on all my
devices to make it much more difficult
for them to exploit my data for their
own profits and the best part is how
easy it is to use expressvpn i just tap
one button on my phone or computer to
turn it all on and that's all it takes
to keep people out of my business
if you don't like big tech tracking you
and selling your personal data for
profit it's time to fight back visit
expressvpn.com slash tim dillon right
now to get three months of expressvpn
for free that's expressvpn.com slash tim
dillon expressvpn.com tim dillon we use
it all the time everyone everyone is
here right now everyone i've ever met is
using it to be honest with you um i was
reading this article and i sent it to
ben about children being medicated
uh and i took adderall briefly when i
was a youngster in um
uh eighth grade and it just you know i
don't know i just got a dry mouth it
didn't really work i mean i got a little
speedy
but you know the grades didn't go up so
i think my parents were like okay let's
not do it anymore um but this is
interesting this teen was and by the way
i think people need medic medication so
don't this isn't one of those things
where i say no one needs medication i
think certain people need to be on their
medication i have them in my family and
i know
but there is you know this teen here was
prescribed 10 psychiatric drugs
uh
she's not alone one morning in the fall
of 2017 renee smith a high school
freshman on long island new york
interesting
could not get out of bed overwhelmed by
the prospect of going to school in the
following days her anxiety mounted into
despair i should have been happy she
later wrote but i cried screamed begged
the universe or whatever godly power to
take away the pain
of a thousand men that was trapped
inside my head
intervention for depression and anxiety
came not from the divine but from the
pharmaceutical industry
the following spring a psychiatrist
prescribed prozac the medication
uh we all associate with you know
depression um however she kept taking it
the effect dissipated she was uh
prescribed an additional antidepressant
affects her
um
[Music]
during 2021 the year she graduated she
was prescribed
seven
drugs
these included one for seizures and
migraines which neither she didn't have
any of either one of those
but the drug can also be used to
stabilize mood and another to dull the
side effects of the other medications
although it's mainly used for
schizophrenia she felt better on some
days and deeply sad on others her senior
yearbook photo shows her smiling broadly
quote but i feel terrible that day said
miss smith who is now 19 and attends a
local community college i've gotten good
at wearing a mask
um
she had come to exemplify medical
practice common among her generation the
simultaneous use of multiple heavy-duty
psychiatric drugs
psychiatrists and other clinicians
emphasizes psychiatric drugs properly
prescribed can be vital in stabilizing
adolescents and saving the lives of
suicidal teens but these experts caution
such medications are too readily doled
out often as an easy alternative to
therapy that families cannot afford or
find so that's an interesting
that's really an interesting thing
people do we have better help this week
i don't think we do actually
would have been nice
well anyway
for a waste
people can't get therapy and they can't
afford it and the doctors are just
cramming pills down the throats of the
you know a lot of people
every now and then you'll meet a kid
that you it needs to be immediately
drugged and you can tell and i've you
know i have friends with children where
the child is like
and you go
lock it in the cage
you go put the drugs in it and lock it
in a cage because some people have kids
that have problems you see
big problems
okay like my you know one of my friend's
kids like he was on his tippy toes a lot
he would just meet a kid like that
they're on their tippy toes they're
going like this and i'm like
yeah
there you go all right that's that's not
going to get solved by a catch in the
front yard right
catch isn't going to help that like
throwing a ball that's not going to help
that i didn't even know what it was but
on the tippy toes and then he would go
like this he got
so
in those rare instances when it's not
going to be solved with a game of catch
or some wheat bread
it's not solved with taking away some
ice cream
it's a real
problem
you got to sedate the children drug them
up
put the drugs in them and put them in
the cage because they are a problem
hyperactive
i don't know but you you meet them every
now and then you're you're at a party
it's a nice barbecue
and then you know it's like the the it's
the running of the bulls the barn door
opens and out comes like oh my god what
the [ __ ] is this
and i don't know how it happened or what
happened
but the kid's a [ __ ] lunatic and you
go if this kid's not medicated they will
kill
somebody or themselves they'll burn
something down they're a liability
some kids are a liability and they need
to be drugged because
they're [ __ ] nuts
and i'm not a doctor and that's not the
clinical term but that's what happens
you've seen some of these kids right
yeah i mean they they have hard times
understanding what reality is you
explain to them that roblox isn't real
it's not real life they're like what do
you mean but i'm in the game my friends
are that's everybody my point is when
they're actually that's not that's not
what i mean what i mean is not a kid
who's quietly playing a video game who
thinks it's real that's fine think it's
real just shut up
my point is a kid who's like yeah yeah
[Applause]
yeah you wanna make my dog you wanna
make my dog you wanna meet my dog you
wanna meet my dog you wanna be my
you know what i mean just where it's
like it's like okay okay i'll meet your
dog later i'll meet your dog later i've
already met your dog i've already met
get the [ __ ] going
those people need to be drugged some of
those kids cause some of those kids have
severe severe severe severe issues
but then there are those other kids in
school and you know the kids who are
like they're sad they're like i'm sad
and i don't want it anymore like
i just don't want it
i'm so sad
and that's very sad so maybe give him a
little pill you give him a little blue
pill and go take a walk around the track
every town
has a little track that no one uses
you to take a walk around the track and
you have to take a little bit here's a
little pill here's a little pill you're
a little over dramatic
but you can't give him like 13 types of
medication
this is a problem
if you're really problem like if you
really have an issue where it's like
you're like i just wait
and i'm not even i'm not trying to make
light of these things because people
have
they have genuine issues with depression
anxiety my mother is a schizophrenic i
call it schizophonic
because she's locked up now so it's just
fun she doesn't really bother anyone
key please
um but i get it i've had anxiety uh
myself i have problems with myself so
much of
this is about it's case by case you know
what i mean so there's people that are
severely
anxious and depressed that need
medication to function in life and then
there are people who are having
situational depression
who with cognitive behavioral therapy
they can improve their lives greatly
that includes changes in diet that
includes
maybe exercise that includes uh
moderation of drugs and or alcohol even
marijuana which everybody loves can
exacerbate underlying mental health
issues this is a fact
right
so not everybody is a well-adjusted
person there's a lot of people i'm nuts
and everyone i know is nuts now we're
talented
you know but i'm telling you this
i know a lot of people that are need to
be on medication and i'm not saying that
medication is not good but i'm also
saying we are an over-medicated country
because there are certain like sometimes
i will eat something i shouldn't eat if
i eat like a big ice cream sundae i feel
happy i go oh i like it it feels good
but then you then it gets tied to god oh
i'm sad now
because the sugar high's over the high
the sugar's over the insulin crash comes
and then you're just like oh i didn't i
why did i do it and then you're
disgusted with yourself and you're like
i've been bad i've been bad
and you get upset and these negative
feelings and listen that can happen with
booze it can happen with food it can
happen with
any of these things right it can happen
with
laziness and sloth if you don't do it
you don't want to accomplish the things
you're doing
you then get disgusted and it becomes
this negative feedback loop where you're
like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
those are more situational things that
can be helped by lifestyle changes and
maybe some light medication tiny pill
walk around the track walk around at 7
30 at night have a jasmine tea get in
your bed nut
get in your bed and don't be a nut
now there's some people that have deeper
problems than that where it's very bad i
had a friend named andrea
you know ready it's gonna be bad
you know already
it's going to be a bit i liked andrea a
lot she was a witch
a modern witch a wiccan
very mortal
and i liked andrew a lot
she was fun
she was sick
when i was a young person she was part
of my group my group included skaters
stoners goths
and uh drug dealers
um
i guess they were jocks i mean some of
them were you know they were it's not
they weren't being drafted but they some
of them were
you know able-bodied for sure physical
you know they would fight people and you
know brandish weapons
when you know when need be
uh but we we had a big tent because
drugs and that's the beautiful things
about drugs that's why i recommend them
is that it is a great big tent
so
you would have and she was a lovely goth
girl
and she had a big um
um
knife
that she would cut herself with
not always
not always
not in front of you
understand what i'm saying
she was a witch
she wore all black which i like i still
like that i still like that
she was a witch and she cut herself with
a big knife
and she had a lot of weed and we all
smoked weed with her and when she was
happy
when a depressed person is happy it's so
beautiful because they're not usually
happy she was manic i believe she was
manic depressive
and she would be so and we would laugh i
mean she was fun there were times
when we would just sit there
in the back of the library
because no one ever went long island to
the libraries and many people use drugs
there in the back of them because no one
goes to them
and and the people that work there don't
really pay attention because no one goes
to the lie unless you're like like an
older like a guy like my uncle who like
goes in and he's like i want a book on
ulysses s grant and it's like hey
shut up
but you know like he'll go in and get a
book on ulysses s grant and then go go
and do the back room of his house and
drink
um
and but
we'd be sitting in the back of the
library
me her and my friend
and we would smoke pot and just start
laughing so hard nobody even said
anything
nobody even said anything
but it was just the fun
the humanity
and i believe she was in many mental
institutions like over and over again i
think she's dead now
i think she's dead but i don't here's
the thing i don't know
she might be alive she was a witch
and she had a big knife
my point is that
there are people out there with problems
you know what i mean
[Music]
i don't know if she's dead or not
if she's not dead don't dm me i don't i
don't play that game anymore i you know
i've moved on
but the point is
what i am saying and it's it's
it's hard to make this coherent but i
think the people out here that are
really connecting with it are
understanding what i mean
what i mean is that
this person
had problems but was a beautiful person
that i believe
i believe now is dead but i don't know i
don't know if she's dead or not
but
fun times
somebody who would just giggle
like a like a like a hyena she would
cackle like a mad woman and then run off
with her knife into the night
these are the memories
that if you if you're not making the
memories
i think she's dead
my point is that
you have to be careful with this
medication
because
had we medicated her earlier on
those beautiful moments that we
experienced
i don't know you know maybe they
wouldn't have been uh it wouldn't have
been around
i i hate to sound selfish about it
but she was a fun person
we met her like twice
two or three times
[Laughter]
but when you're on drugs and you hang
out with somebody back then back in the
late 90s and early 2000s when you hung
out with somebody was like all day all
night people used to go out at 11 a.m
and get back at 5 00 a.m
all day all night there were different
drugs for different hours the gold it
was always nice weed in the golden hour
the gloaming the the sunset and then the
coke was at night but i mean you know
like or the hallucinogens or whatever
you were doing that night but you know i
was in the grocery store a few a few
minutes ago and the guy was talking to
his girlfriend i agree he's like yeah
they're all from the bay area they're
really into hallucinogens they're like
super smart guys i'm hanging out with
them this weekend they always get into
something [ __ ] crazy i'm like the
whole state's just drug addicts the
entire state is people that are just in
some form
of like psychosis it's crazy they're
really smart guys for the bay area
they're like super into hallucinogens
i'm hanging out with them this weekend
they always get into something
and she was like yeah she goes i only go
out on friday and saturday nights and
because that's really like respectable
that's like a california conversation
that's really respectable you do i only
got on friday and saturday night that's
really respectable they're from the bay
area they're bringing their lucians
i met a guy he told me his jobs he
provides drugs for the rolling stones i
said no way get keith richards on the
phone and he did and i played
satisfaction and he liked it so you know
he's a drug dealer but you never know
what i'm saying is that with the drugs
and the children you have to be careful
with it all right what else do we have
there's some other things but that's the
message really i think it's pretty
coherent i think i explained it well la
voters in los angeles will decide if the
homeless could be housed in vacant hotel
rooms
we got about 20 000 empty hotel rooms
we've got 20 000 empty hotel why
wouldn't people come here
so there's 20 000 empty hotel rooms here
where people well there's so many of
these hotels they're just dumps right
oh a lot of them right a lot of these
things are like it dumps and you know
why wouldn't you put a homeless people
in the hotel
right yeah yeah oh yeah
they're all surrounded lax they're not
filled anymore you know
right so a lot of these because i mean
if you're staying by lax i mean you're
just doing drugs you're cheating on your
wife i mean there's no or you're like
maybe of some crazy like layover you
want to sleep for six hours i don't know
but nobody there's only really here's
reality here's reality
there's one hotel to stay in if you
visit los angeles it's called the
beverly hills hotel
okay
and frankly
you have to stay there and it's about
1100 at night or maybe 1400 at night
yeah
um
you have to stay there if you don't stay
there don't come
don't come
don't come what did kamala harris say
don't come do not come do not come
if you cannot say the beverly hills and
here's why i'm not trying to be classist
i'm telling you
everything else sucks well hotel belair
oh yeah yeah it's hotel bel air very
nice
there's beverly hills hotel
the waldorf is fine as well
do not go near santa monica
it's a mad house
there's nothing really in malibu to stay
there's nowhere to stay i'm not even
making this up folks i'm not you know
what i mean
downtown is a ritz but it's a dump
um
i'm genuinely i'm like racking my brain
there's like nothing you got to go to
manchester like san ysidro rancho
rosewood in miramar i'm telling you
unless you're like like have a flu
you're a young person and you just want
to come here to like [ __ ] get [ __ ]
up and hang like that's a whole
different story you're obviously you'll
have a friend you'll have a couch you'll
stay in a cheap place if you're an older
person and you're actually visiting
california and you go listen we're gonna
spend five grand on a trip and we're
gonna stay somewhere nice for two or
three nights
whatever it is like i'm telling you
there's there's a dearth of good options
here
there's not a lot i'm not i'm not there
is uh in pasadena they have the one that
i've stayed at a few times the langham
oh the langham is yeah it's really nice
yeah
there's a few there's really a few but
there's not a ton and i'm not trying
everyone's like oh you make money now
you're a big [ __ ] i'm like yeah maybe
but i'm telling you the truth new york
there's so many hotels here there's just
not a lot of hotels and the ones that
are left are going to be um filled with
the homeless and that's okay too because
i say just give it to them
manoj patel is the manager at an la
motel 6. he voluntarily rents some rooms
to homeless people who are vetted and
paid for by a local church
quote
honestly would you check into a hotel
knowing the chances of your neighbor to
the left or to the right is a homeless
individual no offense if you're staying
at a motel 6 you lose the right
to demand that the people next you
aren't homeless
really it's a motel 6.
right
you're sticking to motel 6. i imagine
the people that are staying in the room
next to me are either homeless or
they'll be homeless within three months
it's a [ __ ] motel 6.
if you're an extended stay america if
you're at an extended stay america a
motel sax even the lower ends of the
best oh the safari in burbank shout out
oh shout out shout out to the safari in
burbank
but
you know this idea now they're not gonna
put these people to beverly hills hotel
lose my [ __ ] mind they can't do it oh
that would be if they do that
if they do that i will i will i will be
on a tank with ron desantis
in this town with a rocket launcher
places need to be [ __ ] nice i'm sorry
what do you think civilization's about
you [ __ ] slugs
stop trying to ruin everything and make
everything ugly and [ __ ]
some places need to be you can you can
put these people in the best western i
don't give a [ __ ] let him take shits at
the [ __ ] continental breakfast i
don't care it is what it is i stayed in
those hotels for years doing comedy i i
don't give a [ __ ] i smoke in the room
when i go to those places i act like a
homeless person in those hotels so i
have no problem with them being in those
hotels but if i see them at the beverly
hills hotel i'm going to get rick caruso
and we're going to come here with
caitlyn jenner and [ __ ] we are going
to light [ __ ] up
they cannot be at hotel bel air that
cannot be the beverly hills uh hotel
you know i mean
it's just what it is
you can't have it all
i don't know i mean what do you think
about this the homeless in the hotels
also i forgot four seasons in west like
shout out to them as well yes four
seasons in west side but there's no
reason to stay there the restaurant is
great but there's really no reason to
stay there
unless you what are you doing
you know
the only attraction
at the four seasons in westlake is my
fat agent
now if you want to bring your kids
and show them him
you know it is
kind of a marvel
it's not nothing
but that's the only attraction it's
probably better than the santa monica
beer
you could feed him and
he does
he does a few tricks not many
you toss him bacon he grabs the phone he
calls zany's in nashville
we should do a show on that well i did
that to ryman recently
anyway i mean that's what it is we have
anything else here i i don't care about
these hotels anymore mm-hmm put everyone
anywhere
i you know people say to me all the time
what do you get somebody what do you get
somebody i said you go to box of
austin.com and you get them the bespoke
post it's a box they ship it once a
month it is amazing no matter what
you're into they have a different box
for you from must-have travel items to
camping gear essentials if you're an
outdoorsman if you love booze they have
cool stuff to become like a bartender
i'm telling you and it's all from
american companies each box of awesome
you're supporting small businesses 90 of
everything is is from a small
up-and-coming brand it's free to sign up
and you can skip a month or cancel any
time box of awesome is
really amazing
right i mean
you can get a gift for somebody that
keeps giving throughout the year they
never forget
[Music]
i mean i enjoy this so much what was
your favorite box of awesome you've
gotten so they just sent me this bag
that i'm actually taking to europe and
it's very fancy and european wait
it what it's this bag that opens it has
like a hard bottom to it and it's it's
really like fashionable and stuff so i
don't have to like just walk around my
with my backpack like i'm a 12 year old
you know i can be like an adult you got
a bag that you're taking to europe yeah
yeah do you know what box i do want to
get what the scorch box it says hot
sauces from small brands all over the
country with some from texas nevada
california i hope they send me that one
next
didn't they also send you the river box
it was it came with a diving knife yes
it was lovely
anyway
go to box of awesome.com and enter the
code tim dillon at checkout what's the
coolest thing about this is you can give
someone a gift that actually all year
round
they're enjoying yeah
and by the way it's not a lot of money
no for an entire year for 12 boxes this
is really cool if somebody you know is
going away to college or moving to a new
city
you get them this and they always
remember you
box of awesome.com
awesome's in a box now
[Music]
i love that it's from a small business
though
get twenty percent off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code tim dylan at
checkout that's box of awesome.com
code tim dillon for 20 off your first
box box of awesome.com
you might get a knife
let me tell you right now about athletic
greens they are so athletic and so green
that i don't even know what to do when
i'm on them i take them and it's so easy
it's probiotics they help the stomach
they give you energy it's not coffee
there's no crashing you've got 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole foods
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right it's a special blend that supports
gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
aging all of the things when you take
athletic greens you feel like
is that line from titanic where he goes
i'm the king of the world
isn't that from titanic
are you out of it
i don't think it is i think it is i'm
the king of the world movie
i'm the king of the world wasn't that
titanic
oh it is titanic yeah what's wrong with
you
um he goes i'm the king of the world and
when you take um
this um
athletic greens
you feel like you're the literal king of
the world because oh yeah you have so
much energy
and your gut is healthy
and it just boosts your immune system i
mean there's so much i mean
so to me it's like
i'm like
crazy
it costs you less than three dollars a
day if you're investing in your health
it's cheaper than a cold brew habit
i mean
it's amazing
athletic grains is a athletic greens is
a climate neutral certified company so
really they care about the planet too
and they care about the earth
they've got over seven thousand five
star reviews it's recommended by
professional athletes
i mean everybody loves it now tell your
story with athletic greens so here's
what's great is like yeah it comes with
like all the vitamin d and all that
stuff you need to take that stuff so you
have good gut health and so you feel
healthy in the in the brain how did you
not know i'm the king of the world was
from titanic
because i thought it was he's on this
front of this i'm the king of the world
yes leo leo's on the on the front of the
ship right
maybe he took athletic greens and then
he went to the front of the ship it
wasn't around then it's literally it was
it's literally
new
right yes it is new
he could have found them but anyway
these supplements you need
huberman talks about this a lot you take
stuff like this andrew huberman you
talked about how this stuff makes you
happy you need a you can't be a mount uh
you need all the nutrients you might not
be getting them
you know eating you know like waffles
that you put in your pocket remember uh
sad guru yes said guru sad guru says
there's not enough uh stuff in the soil
like magnesium and
[ __ ] love me some sad guru so sad
guru would probably say you need to take
this stuff
said guru is a king
it's for kings you want to be a king or
not and queens
and in the middles
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticreads.com tim dillon again that
is athleticqueens.com tim dillon to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
oh drew barrymore this is interesting to
me drew barrymore is being accused of
racism
um
by black tick talkers for copying black
men frolicking trend after posting
innocent video of herself enjoying the
rain
guys
this is uh insane and
first of all
drew barrymore let's be very honest
doesn't really know what she's doing
right like can we say that
can we just say that drew barrymore
is not exactly aware of what's going on
you don't own frolicking i've never seen
black men frolic
or any men frolic
unless they're gay and i would i will
never suck off a man who's frolicking
so the reality is i don't even know what
this trend is or who claims to own it
but this is just a sweet mentally
uh enfeebled woman
dancing in the rain she has a show on
television
somehow
and she is a very sweet
friendly
talented woman
who is really no longer in control of
her frontal cortex
and i don't think she should be blamed
for anything at all ever including
murder if drew barrymore walked in right
now and killed me she doesn't know what
she's doing and she didn't mean it
so can we can we play this video of her
yeah and i'll show you the trend too but
this is the video people are very upset
about
whenever you can go out into the rain do
not miss the opportunity yeah she's not
where is she new york
uh it appears that way never rains
nothing like that is in l.a anyway
there's no rain here this is just a
dress as stephen king novel this is the
uh this is sort of a compilation of like
the videos that are oh my god
i'm frolicking tell me we was frolicking
[Music]
okay this is disgusting to be honest i
don't know what this is but i i mean
this is like crazy
the world's lost his [ __ ] mind
um and so people are angry at her
because she went out into the rain i
mean do don't you see how [ __ ] stupid
all these people are
don't you see how [ __ ] dumb these
people are
i don't know what to tell you anymore
but can't you
wrap your head around
how trigger-happy these [ __ ] online
mobs are
how they're trying to make all these
connections that don't exist
drew barrymore should be able to go out
into the rain all right let's get this
out what else this is i mean you know
drew barrymore
trump is uh
trump's dealing with it what may come
next an inquiry with legal peril uh i
don't know they're they're saying he had
uh documents and the cia was saying that
uh confidential informants were being
killed around the world and that trump
had documents
um
potentially massive in light of what we
now know in october 2021 cia
counterintelligence sent a top-secret
cable warning an unusual number of
confidential informants were being
killed captured or compromised in
january 2021 trump stole documents on
these kind of informants basically
they're alleging that trump
uh and his family are through
intermediaries is selling information to
foreign governments i think that's what
they're kind of that's what they're
interested in i mean and again it's a
very massive big insinuation of which
there isn't that much evidence other
than the fact that he was in possession
of these documents but you know this
will this will uh develop more in time
and we'll figure out i i put nothing
past the trump crew i don't know what
they're doing i also put nothing past
the cia so it's it's a fun tennis match
but
let's watch these things because
children were serving food into
mcdonald's and people were very
uncomfortable this this made me laugh
out loud
quote i'm not coming back here
mcdonald's customers react to seeing
kids behind the counter in the
louisville location
a spokesperson for mcdonald's said the
children in the video are not employees
customers spoke out wednesday after
witnessing kids behind the counter at
louis at a louisville mcdonald's
restaurant nathan pitts and his
girlfriend annette cardwell said they go
to the mcdonald's on taylor boulevard
often
however their sunday night was the first
time seeing underage kids inside it was
a school night they should have been in
bed
cardwell and pitt said two children were
taking and making orders at 11 p.m
they looked as young as 10 years old
the couple added that they were so
disgusted by what they saw they
immediately asked for their money back
so they walked into and make that you
walk into a mcdonald's you see kids
behind the counter you're leaving you're
eating i'm eating
fillet of fish oh yeah mcdouble no
mustard mcflurry
small fry i mean i am eating
is there a video of one of the children
working so this is the video they have
here
this was nathan pitt's reaction after
pulling up to the window at the
mcdonald's it's blurred out obviously
and wonder why the lions wrapped around
because i got these little kids up in
this one pitts and his girlfriend
annette cardwell say they come to this
mcdonald's often however they say sunday
was their first time seeing underage
kids inside it was a school night they
should have been in bed they're working
says the two children were taking and
making orders at 11 at night shut your
mouth and get to mcrib
stop being arrested
stop being a rat
get your [ __ ] fries and leave
it's not your business
are they running the operation properly
are they making the mcflurries are they
[ __ ] is everything hot and ready to
go if it is who cares
why are we
limiting
what children can do
let them manage at mcdonald's
keep going it looks like they're
accepting the food here they do yeah i'm
sure they did by the way this is to
protect their identity cobwell says they
looked as young as 10 years old the fact
that these kids just handed me my drinks
is pissing me off
but those kids should not have been
behind that counter at all the couple
says they were so disgusted by what they
saw they immediately started recording
and asked for their money back i need a
refund
i need a refund i'm sorry i need a
refund i went to the mcdonald's today to
get some answers the general manager
says the owner told her she's not
allowed to comment on this situation i
also reached out to mcdonald's corporate
office a spokesperson for the company
says quote we are aware of the incident
and can confirm that the minors shown in
the video are not employees of the
restaurant they are children of some of
the employees while we are proud to
employ many parents and caregivers and
understand that sometimes kids may visit
a parent's workplace minors who are not
employees are not permitted behind the
counter we have taken action to ensure
that all of our employees are reminded
of our policies regarding visitors as
for pitts and caldwell they say
mcdonald's officially lost two lawyer
customers i'm not coming back here
okay well great
i wonder if mcdonald's will survive
i hate i don't like rats man
and i don't like the the idea that
people are you know
somebody brought their kids to work and
they're like hey why don't you get
behind the counter and start [ __ ]
i'm a little drugged up today
why don't you get behind the counter and
help mom out cause mom's a little high
and can you take some orders while i
[ __ ] try to straighten up splash some
cold water on my face
this isn't a very american story and
it's actually beautiful
a child visits their mother who's high
who's working at mcdonald's she's too
high to take orders so she says to her
children can you help mom out can you
take the orders while i try to sober
myself up
missouri school district revives
paddling to disciplined students this is
odd
man missouri is a real uh
it's a really interesting place and by
interesting i mean a uh whole
i mean i've been there i mean man can
you imagine no offense if you live there
i mean you know god bless
comics you're supposed to like
everywhere so if i go to that place i'm
supposed to sell tickets there
um so they're supposed to like every
place and they're not supposed to insult
any place right well then don't listen
to the show and don't come
because i don't care
formerly known as what am i going to
pretend that formerly corporal
punishment the disciplinary measure
usually involves striking students on
the buttocks with a wooden paddle and
cassfield staff members will employ
quote reasonable physical force without
quote a chance of bodily injury or harm
in the presence of a witness
wait what
interesting so i guess they can't hit
him too hard basically that's what
they're saying right and someone also
has to be in the room which that that's
how it was when i got spanked too i
think yeah well this is just insane i
mean you grew up in hell i mean listen
the reality is
it's just this is what happens when a
country's completely falls apart
and this is like people are like going
to like
you know they're going to start whacking
kids with paddles
in school
i just don't understand
i i i you know if you came home and
you're like a teacher hit me with a pal
i mean you know
i just i i don't think it's necessary i
think you should be able to discipline
children without hitting them with a
paddle
you know
is this the only other option we have
besides drugging them that's unfortunate
so we have to either give them 19
medications or hit them with a paddle
these are the two these are the two
options we have
in the quote greatest country in the
world where everyone's such a [ __ ]
smart resourceful person the only way
you can deal with children is to attack
them
hit them
with a paddle or drug them
[Music]
give them antipsychotic medicate like
it's just crazy uh it's not new in
schools and um my father was paddled and
blah blah blah and the catholic school
the nuns would hit him with a ruler you
know and
um
what what which town in missouri is this
i guess it's i think it's statewide i
believe or it's a school district so it
says
asheville yeah go to house for seattle
castle missouri okay
house for sale castle missouri okay
let's see here see what we're working
with here
let's see if we can get a selling sunset
franchise okay realtor.com okay i prefer
zillow okay let me go back to zillow
here we go casseville missouri
uh ain't cheap
wow none of this is cheap
what's interesting is these are actually
really pretty homes
um some of them are in the low end you
know below two below 300 but for the the
homes we're seeing here a lot of these
some of them dip
some of them are really nice homes
but go down go down there's more there's
more to the story here
go to that 67 5
this is what we're talking about yeah
this is this is where yeah
yeah oh lord imagine
yes i mean those are the people who they
go you want us to hear your kids and
they go yeah please we'll hit him let's
all kill him there's a dog in one of the
real estate photos is that a real dog
yeah he's like chained up too there is a
chain dog in one of the real estate
photos lovely
there it is
i like the kitchen lots of natural light
i like the rotted wood
it makes me think a horror movie scene i
can imagine blood spilling out into the
sink
let's see what the primary bedroom's
like
ashtray
great [ __ ] yeah
i like see i like when you've punched
through a wall and you conceal it with a
blanket that you hang on the wall
nothing wrong with that
man
yeah they didn't show us the primary
unless that's the primary
not the master
get the realtor on the phone right now
who's representing the property
uh i'm telling you right now i want to
know
i want to know who is representing the
property
um
i'll call them in two seconds
it's dipped in value it says has it yeah
it was up to like 70 at some point well
it's a good time it's a good time to buy
call larry
call larry right now
because i have
a few questions about this property
okay i'm connecting
and let's dial let's see if any answers
i mean no one works anymore no
nobody's good for anything in this
[ __ ] country but maybe larry lancer
would help sell me this house
look if his number
he's a good man i just want to make sure
this is in the school district where the
kids are getting hit
that's my biggest concern right now with
this property is that this is in the
school district where the children are
being uh this is him that's great okay
she tries office or sell sell
he's out it's a weekend it's a saturday
right yeah that's when they work that's
when real estate agents should work okay
here we go
what town is this cass casseville
cassville missouri
hello you have reached the voicemail
you want to leave a voicemail if you
will leave me your name
number yeah short message i will return
your call have a good day
at the tone please record your message
when you've finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
larry how are you my name is brandon
schaub i'm looking for a property uh in
cassville and i see that you're the guy
there a couple of my friends have
recommended to me
that you are the guy there's a beautiful
home on harold street that looks like a
real like a fixer-upper
and i just wanted to make sure that it
was still on the market it wasn't in
escrow and it was in the school district
where the kids were able to get paddled
because i have a few kids myself and
quite frankly corporal punishment is
exactly what they need
so assuming that the taxes are good i'd
love to move forward thank you and give
me a ring back when you can
okay hung up all right
thanks for watching everyone we'll
update you but i think this is a great
investment property uh
timdylandcomedy.com nothing on sale yet
things might be on sale merch dropping
very soon we've gone to some we've made
some really really cool merch stuff
that's coming so at timdylandcomedy.com
can they sign up to be alerted when
merge comes out yeah they can oh my god
not only the special tim dillon the real
hero on netflix if you care and then go
to the bottom of the website sign up for
go to the bottom of the website sign up
for the merch the merch is really cool
we've got the knife fight shirt and
hoodies and everything coming out
new fake business stuff i wish them well
uh ben's gonna cut a really cool promo
um and we will see everybody else thank
you for spending your saturday night
with us and oh
um
what else was i gonna say
um yeah
yeah watch the special if you can and um
tell a friend we want it we want netflix
to be happy with the numbers they are
certainly
um
but uh yeah
do you have anything to add i'll put a
link for the netflix special so you can
just click it i'll take you right to it
how easy is that how easy is that
do you have anything to add in closing
uh the the ipad thing what well the
thing with the kit i was gonna say when
you take the ipad away from the kid i
was gonna say they go nuts they start
squirming and going crazy that's why i
wasn't like i wasn't doing like a
non-sequitur thing
what
when you asked me if i knew a kid like
that that was crazy and i told you the
thing about like roblox and stuff oh
yeah i was i was getting to the i
sounded very like a fool i wanted to
just go back to it real quick
you sounded like a fool then
yeah so i just wanted to clarify that
that part i was getting to the thing
where i was
i didn't want to make it look like i was
just telling a story about a child i
once knew i was trying to connect it to
what you were saying
noted
that's what i would like to add i'd like
to go on the record
noted
well
there's that
have fun in europe with your wife
oh yeah going to europe isn't that nice
mm-hmm
if you see ben in europe say hello to
him
right no um
if you're in austria some time off tim
dillon grants time off has tim dylan
does tim dillon go go venting around
europe no because i'm a workhorse and
all i do is work all i do is work for
the betterment of the community and
myself and him and everyone but i
understand he's gallivanting through
europe but what will i i'll be working
as i always am and i always will be
because there are kings and there are
titans and then there are every there's
everybody else and uh have a good time
and i hope you enjoy it
i don't know what that means keep your
mouth shut
before you're [ __ ] replaced
i'll go get that [ __ ] producers
crisis podcast i'll be sitting here in
five minutes
all right everyone good luck